I would really be singing in English
classes and reading The Wine Spectator
like there was just no controlling my
insanity
[Music]
this was last Monday morning a delight
if you think a lots happened in the last
10 years wait till you see what happens
over the next 10 years the stakes are
enormous Lehigh and I'm not here
fear-mongering this is just what's
happening ah very honestly the fact that
you're the creme de la creme of the this
this is like I assume that the majority
of people in this room are like yes this
is the opportunity this is where I
transition from a six million dollar a
year business to a fifteen million
dollar a year business this one I
transition from one hundred eighty
thousand dollars a year business to a
2.9 million dollars this is pure
opportunity the problem is and this is
where everybody defaults into they razor
Gary I didn't grow up with this me
neither Carl
I didn't grow up with this either Carl
and guess what Carl you didn't grow up
driving and you figured it out
understanding the digital landscape and
what our consumers are doing on it is
now oxygen for businesses that's awesome
Thank You Darwin give me kiss thank you
for having me yes I did open up take
care
thanks for listening bye guys thank you
for listening bye thank you take care of
it
thank you brother thanks Michael bye
let's name it the 2017 small business
talk rock yo yo yo yo twitter twitter
twitter what's going on good to see you
guys
morning I'm in Louisiana headed to head
to Vegas for CES I've got a phone call
in a few minutes but just want to jump
on to Twitter and give you guys some
love see how you're doing
and maybe we'll jump on a little bit and
see see how we do this so hope you guys
are doing super well I hope life is good
and you have this new jacket is fly if
you love it you rock right well good
stuff Dublin what's up good to see you
now Patriots no way yeah anyway see ya
catchable bringing my friends that's
really generous take care of yourself
all right thank you
I'm gonna try to add more context of
days in the time that I got off stage
and drove this airport
one of our big new scopes for last year
I've got cut in half from 2 million to 1
million which is a problem because the
scale the dollars was gonna help it be
more successful and one of the CEOs of
one of my successful startups is having
some cultural issues where the team is
struggling so that's hardcore
and so very quickly in two seconds -
pretty substantial flyers but you take
them in the in the in the micro at the
moment and then you start leveling them
up to a macro right yeah I take the hit
I absorb it now I'm thinking and
pondering and now I'm already
strategizing on how to fix it
I think way too many people spend too
much time dwelling and they allow
something like this to ruin our day or
ruin a Rico we're in their month over
when they're a year I think one of the
things I talk about is having a stomach
having the stomach for this game is
exactly what I refer to i I've been
around a lot of executives a lot of
partners who would use something like
this as a day ender as I call it
and I've come to realize how much of a
strength that is a mind of putting
things in the proper contact centers and
dealing with reality and you know when
you're an entrepreneur you're a
firefighter especially if you're the
last line of defense it's all on you
there's no there's no pumping it down
right now we have a potential conflict
issue of like what's your count do we go
to I'm like trying to keep Marcus from
office Co give me a day give me a day
but the truth is I'm not accomplishing
anything you know I'm just thinking I'm
trying to ponder but the quicker you
make actions quicker you can adjust to a
negativity big blows medium blows large
blows the turnaround speed and your
adjustment to an issue is usually an
unbelievable proxy to the level of
success you will have as an entrepreneur
so you need to start conditioning
yourself for the emotional war that
entrepreneurship is
what are you doing now right now I'm
answering an a a for mogul media site
and I'm an investor in great
entrepreneur she asked me and really not
what I want to be using my time on but I
think you have to come through for the
partnerships you make and so she doesn't
ask often and so even though it's a
tough week and things of that nature I'm
doing this AMA on their site on mobile
comm and oh and in mobile comm and crank
away at answer is just trying to get
through her bunch so I can get the
security here somebody asked me about a
time in my life when I was going through
a struggle and how I got through and
made me think about 2005 when I turned
30 and I realized that my actions were
not backing up my words I've been I've
said that a couple of times if you have
the audacity the dream you have to make
you actions you have to do it and I had
a moment like that I was very successful
I built a huge business and I would say
Fu's 28 to 30 I probably got caught into
some form of complacency we were growing
like crazy but it was completely
compared to the ambition that I set out
to accomplish and so from 20 to 30 I was
building a big business a big winery
ecommerce business I was innovating I
was hustling but I wasn't working as
hard as I am now I wasn't doing
strategically smart things that were
gonna allow me to achieve the
professional things that I wanted and I
wasn't so over capitalizing on my family
time of Lizzy in return either so it
wasn't like I was getting someone me
and so 22:30 is an interesting time for
me because I think that there was so
much success so fast that I got caught
for 24 months of maybe not hustling as
hard and as smart as I could and more
importantly on my 30th birthday I
realized I wasn't gonna buy the New York
Jets
and that's kind of weirdly okay as you
guys know I walked out but that's okay
what crushed me was I was full of [ __ ] I
wasn't I wasn't putting into work at a
macro and micro level to give me a
chance to buy the New York Jets just got
into Vegas connected in Houston ladies
at the rock to come off the plane CES
for a couple of days day and a half and
then back on the grind in the Seattle to
try to sign a kid we were in our sports
just did a bunch of email the eBay
challenges out of control the 21 savage
moment in the askgaryvee show coffee
people's attention so what's going on
ambition I have and the excitement I
have is the process of trying to buy the
New York Jets versus buying them and so
yeah I think I think that era was
interesting to me and so when I tell you
that your actions have to back up your
words I come from a place of experience
because I live a couple years here where
I did it and and I know what it tastes
like
right and I got a new place where I
really spoke to myself from November 14
2005 through just probably January 15th
2005 and then February 28 2006 febrile
to those but at six
I started Wine Library TV and started
taking the internet more seriously and
no rest was history
[Music]
when I was 15 years old I signed up for
your catalog and would post it in my
room
like it was a Pamela Anderson poster
MacArthur's is legitimately one of the
seven or eight stores that I picked up
to what before I build Wine Library
that's really cool like that is like
that was such an amazing time in my life
where I was still in high school but
knew that who I was gonna be and we're
like literally this is not a joke
would you take and read it in the middle
of English class like the level of
disrespect that I had for my future so I
would really be singing English class
and reading The Wine Spectator like
there was just no controlling my
insanity just leaving the media link
party and now heading to a Carbone
dinner with a bunch of friends just
hustling CS is grind 18 19 hour days
meeting after meeting in Vegas trying to
make it happen so see what's up
[Music]